cumple esta reforma con el objetivo
recaudar fondos para reducir el déficit
sin afectar a la clase media
buenas noches a que efectivamente la
atribución es muy amplios en términos de
cuánto se desea recaudar y el gobierno
no pensó en cabezas ministro campos
tratan de ser muy cuidadosos en respetar
dos restricciones que tienen en términos
de endeudamiento yo creo que es una
reforma ambiciosa pero que respeta en
principio
la sostenibilidad fiscal del país bueno
y que hay que decir acerca de los
productos de consumo masivo como las
bebidas azucaradas y los ultra
procesados se está grabando a los
consumidores y no a las grandes
compañías
claramente se está grabando a los
consumidores y ese es precisamente el
objetivo que ellos reduzcan su consumo
de esos pedidas la medida en que ellos
reduzcan su consumo de este tipo de
bebidas las empresas se verán forzadas a
reducir el contenido de azúcar de sus
bebidas lo cual terminará siendo
beneficioso para su salud bueno y además
hablando de uno de los puntos más
polémicos de esta propuesta de reforma
están las limitaciones al petróleo
enmarcadas en la propuesta verde del
mandatario usted cree que este va a ser
un obstáculo para la aprobación y qué
implicaciones va a tener para la
economía colombiana
y parece mucho más inteligente lo que se
planteó en esta reforma en el sentido de
poner un impuesto sobre ciertos márgenes
sobre los sobre cierto precio del barril
de petróleo en vez de prohibir la
exploración de petróleo que ciertamente
es una medida torpe e ineficiente bueno
y finalmente otro de los temas es el
gravamen de los impuestos que se
impondrán para las personas que ganen
aproximadamente desde 10 millones de
pesos en adelante usted qué opina de
este tope que están poniendo cree que
debería ser menos creo que debería ser
más y por qué
hay un aumento muy importante de la
carga tributaria para estas personas no
hay que tener en cuenta que estas
personas no representan más del 1 por
ciento de la población más rica del país
hay que tener en cuenta que solamente el
5 por ciento de las personas en colombia
declaramos impuesto de renta hay un
margen muy amplio para seguir ampliando
que más gente declara y más gente
contribuye por lo tanto creo que la
reforma es progresiva pero no lo
suficiente debería también hacer más
esfuerzo para que más personas
declaremos y más personándose nos
sintamos corresponsables con la
financiación de las necesidades del país